allez on va passer tout de suite aux
invités du soir on va revenir une
nouvelle fois sur la guerre au sein de
la famille Deon je sais que ça me
passionne et là il y a encore des
rebondissements euh vous le savez
Anthony a déposé donc une main courante
contre sa sœur Anouchka elle a porté
plainte contre Anthony Alain Delon a
également porté plainte contre Anthony
et son fils et Alain Fabien le benjamin
de la famille il est il a répondu
d'ailleurs au Gard au gardes du corps
qui a qui était venu nous voir hier euh
voilà qui était très sympa il lui a
répondu Alain Fabien pourquoi la famille
explose le plan de succession d'Alain
Delon pouri problème à combien s'élève
la fortune d'Alain Delon parce que ça on
l'a pas encore on l' pas on l'a pas
évoqué euh pourquoi Alain Fabien a-t-il
porté plainte petit récap et on aura
Philippe herersen avec nous metteur en
scène d'Ain Doon et très proche d'on qui
nous dira ce qui pense de tout ça et
Nicolas robbot avocat qui nous parlera
bien sûr qui a enquêé sur vraiment
combien ça représente et Gilles verdz
bien entendu qui est là pour nous
empêcher de tourner en
[Rires]
ha depuis plusieurs jours une famille
est au cœur de l'actualité ce soir on va
revenenir sur la guerre au sein de la
famille Delon victime d'un AVC en 2019
l'état de santé Alain Delon fait
aujourd'hui beaucoup parler alors que
ses trois enfants anuska Anthony et
Alain Fabien Delon s'attaquent
juridiquement et se répondent par
interview interposé pour moi éthiquement
c'est très grave voilà d'abord nous
avoir menti nous avoir manipulé je
refuse qu'on me saliss comme ça et qu'on
me traite de manipulatrice ou de
menteuse ou de je ne sais quoi une
famille qui se déchire au grand jour
tandis que l'acteur pourrait laisser
derrière lui un héritage colossal il
aura 320 330 millions d'euros argent
succession plainte révélation et
témoignage de proch dans la de long ce
soir dans
TPMP comment ça va trs bien bonsoir Pour
vous avez le chien vous je sais pas on a
une belle complicité j'aime bien c'est
bien très bien allez on va revenir sur
cette affaire g Verdez merci en tout cas
vous allez nous donner toutes les infos
dans un instant Philippe qui est un pote
merci Philippe d'être là merci beaucoup
qui est producteur producteur qui a
produit les pièces d'alin tout à fa
exactement et Nicolas Rob avocat qui
déjà venu nous voir et voilà qui a
toutes les infos sur ce que ça
représente est-ce qu'on peut refaire un
point et on va venir bien entendu sur la
réponse d'Alain Fabien aujourd'hui sur
voilà on a vu hier ce qui s'était passé
hier on a reçu garde du corps d'Alain
Delon il nous a confié qu'Alain Fabien
se comportait pas toujours bien avec son
pèreoup bruit ce matin exactement ce
matin Alain Fabien long le benjamin de
la famille également annoncé porter
plainte contre sa sœur et également il
nous a répondu est-ce qu'on peut avoir
la réponse d'Alain Fabien si vous l'avez
en régie si vous ne l'avez pas bien
entendu pouvez rentrer chez vous merci
un énorme décalage entre ce que je vois
et comment est-ce que les G ils se
montrent et comment il qu'ils se font
passer pour pour la petite ficherie la
la personne qui est tellement soucieuse
et souciante préoccuper de l'état de
santé de son père et quand je vois qu'en
fait il y a ma sœur qui envoie des
bodyguards nous surveiller déformer la
réalité déformer des propos me menacer
au sein de mon domicile devant mon frère
devant ma niè dans ma maison j'ai bien
déposer plainte contre ma sœur pour abus
de faiblesse et pour un un nombre
incalculable d'autres choses parce que
ce n'est pas que ça qui est
problématique ici c'est très grave tout
ce qui se
passe alors c'est la guerre totale et le
témoignage hier soir sur le plateau a
redéclenché une véritable bataille de
témoignage alors Alain Fabien carrément
il accuse sa sœur de méthodes de crapule
de mafieux donc ça va très très loin
alors il faut bien le dire Cyril tout ça
c'est vraiment une querelle autour de
l'héritage c'est ça l'enjeu central
alors selon Anthony Dolon qui était sur
ces news et c'est pas une question
d'héritage que tout est déjà réglé il
l'exliquait et il a dit comment
l'héritage allait donc être découpé
regardez ce n'est pas un problème
d'héritage ce n'est pas un problème de
succession pourquoi la succession elle
est
réglée problèmes d'argent il y en a pas
tout est
acté donc si vous voulez aujourd'hui et
c'est là où je vais être transparent
c'est très simple ma sœur elle a 50 % de
toute la fortune de mon père mon frère
et moi on est est ce qu'on appelle à la
part de réserve donc on a 25 % c'est
acté c'est terminé c'est fini voilà donc
il y a pas de conflit il y a pas de
guerre de d'héritage tout ça tout ça ça
n'existe pas quel est ce conflit c'est
pas vrai c'est pas fini en fait donc
Alain Delon il a tout à fait le droit
d'attribuer 25 % à chacun des enfants
c'est ça alors c'est c'est le minimum en
franceç minimum c'est5 minimum pour 25
25 25 et la dernière part les 25 % il
fait ce qu'il veut et lui il a décidé de
les donner à Anouka qui aura 50 et qui
sera l'exécutrice testamentaire ça c'est
très important ça veut dire que quand
elle dit oui je suis la préférée elle
est vraiment c'est elle qui va régler
tout après et ça pour les frères c'est
extrêmement compliqué d'où leurs
accusations on les comprend mieux
maintenant de dire Anouchka veut ramener
son père en Suisse elle elle dit que
c'est pour les soins mais eux ils
pensent que c'est pour qu'il soit
résident fiscal suisse et comme elle
dirige les sociétés en Suisse pour
qu'elle ait la main mise vraiment sur
l'héritage voilà alors justement elle
s'estexprimé sur TF1 Mouka et elle a
évoqué l'héritage de son père écoutez
vous savez quand j'ai appris que cet
article sortait dans Paris Match j'ai je
l'ai appris la veille de sa sortie et
j'ai eu envie de me tuer voilà je vous
le dis parce que c'est quelque chose qui
me m'empêche de dormir depuis 3 jours
parce que je refuse qu'on me salisse
comme ça et qu'on me traite de
manipulatrice ou de menteuse ou de je ne
sais quoi euh bien sûr que je porte
plainte euh c'est une horreur de porter
plainte contre son propre frère c'est
terrible je pensais jamais arriver à
quelque chose comme ça dans ma
vie je suis il m'oblige à le faire je
suis obligée de le faire pour moi pour
ma famille alors là c'était l'extrait
sur la plainte mais elle a aussi parlé
de l'héritage de son père c'est ce dont
on parlait il y a un instant on parle de
300 millions d'euros je sais pas vous
savez Audrey en fait ça nous concerne
pas non plus bien sûr que ça nous
concernera après on a l'impression de de
de de parler de notre père comme s'il
était déjà mort moi je suis la fille de
mon père je suis pas la fille d'un
portefeuille cette guerre familiale au
fond c'est une question d'argent non
c'est pas une question d'argent je pense
qu'antthony doit vraiment être en
souffrance en fait pour agir comme ça
j'ai l'impression qu'on me fait payer la
confiance que mon père me porte on a
énormément confiance l'un dans l'autre
c'est comme ça c'est mon fardeau à moi
ouais je vois pas beaucoup je je vois
pas quoi vous dire
d'autre
alors Gill donc on a vu elle c'est pas
exactement l'éritage on va voir les
infos avec Nicolas robot dans un instant
oui on voit bien que dans chacune des
déclarations à chaque fois tous les
ramène à l'héritage et à l'argent Cyril
donc c'est ça la vraie question c'est
que Alain Delon il a privilégié Anouchka
et que les deux frères se sont ligués
parce qu'il ne supportte pas ce partage
voilà c'est une querelle il à l'argent
an alors oui donc Anthony quand il est
sur les plateaux de télé à dire c'est 25
25 il ment alors non non non non ça
c'est vrai m vra il ne ment pas du tout
dit que c'est clair et net qu'il a pas
de polémique on dirait qu'il accepte il
est obligé de l'accepter il a pas le
choix
on peut pas on peut pas il est obligé
d'accepter il pas le choix donc alors on
est avec Nicolas Nicolas robot merci
d'être avec nous à combien s'élève la
fortune d'Alain Delon on les valalue
environ c'est ce que disait Gilles verdz
et ce qu'on dit c'est des centaines de
millions d'euros on est environ à 300
millions d'euros pourquoi parce qu'il y
a du patrimoine immobilier on a une
maison à douchi qui doit être une une
belle propriété douchi c'est près
d'Orléan c'est dans il y a il y a c'est
ça vaut combien ça ça vaut des dizaines
de millions voir peut-être des millions
45 on a dit hier 45 peut-être 45 voilà
donc on est on est de toute façon sur
des belles propriétés on a une propriété
en Suisse il y avait un triplex à Paris
qui qui a été vendu qui était pareil à
proche de 100 millions d'euros il y a
des œuvres d'art qui là encore dont une
partie a été vendu qui ont rapporté 8
millions d'euros il y en a d'autres
encore d'œuvre d'art et puis il y a
quelque chose qui est intéressant chez
Alain Delon c'est que comme acteur il a
aussi été producteur ou co-producteur de
ces films donc il y a un intérêt ensuite
encore là de son vivant et puis
évidemment quand il ne sera plus là
quand les films seront exploités on sait
sa que un acteur comme celui-là qui fait
partie du patrimoine français on sait
que ces films pendant 5 10 ans vont être
beaucoup exploités et là c'est vrai
qu'on a encore une manne financière qui
est intéressante donc c'est pour ça que
tout ça cumulé on atteint une somme qui
dépasse oui les centaines de millions
d'euros 300 millions d'euros alors c'est
Anouka qui va recevoir la plus grosse
part puisque 50 25 25 50 % pour Anouka
donc vous nous confirmez qu'on a le
droit de le faire ici en France on a le
droit de le faire absolument à partir du
moment où la part réservataire
c'està-dire la part des enfants reconnu
par Alain Delon et respecté il reste une
cotité disponible qu'on appelle la
cotité disponible et ça le le le la la
personne qui fait son testament va
pouvoir décider à qui qui le donne soit
il le réparti en ses trois enfants de
manière égale il a le droit de le faire
il le donne à quelqu'un d'autre ou alors
il avantage quelqu'un on sait que avec
Alain Delon il a toujours préféré sa
fille il y a un problème avec ses
garçons il y a un problème avec Anthony
Delon depuis très longtemps les rapports
ont toujours été conflictuel il est très
proche d'anouka on le sait c'est la
fille c'est son enfant du milieu donc à
la famille plus jeune Anthony le plus
vieux mais il a une proximité avec sa
fille elle travaille pour lui elle va
être son exécutrice testamentaire c'est
un rôle important puisqueaprès ça veut
dire qu'elle va devoir faire respecter
non seulement le testament puis après
péréniser l'œuvre de son père les œuvres
de son père donc il a il y a
véritablement aussi on comprend un
intérêt peut-être à l'avantager mais
forcément forcément ça va créer des
jalousies des suspicions et on le voilà
ça éclate au grand jour au moment où
Alain Delon décline ça éclate au grand
jour c'est triste c'est très triste
parce que évidemment ça c'est c'est
devant tout le monde et ça aurait pas
lieu d'être alors s'il déménage
complètement Suisse est-ce que ça va
changer quelque chose pour l'héritage ou
pas du tout non parce qu'à priori je
crois que l'héritage est déjà réglé donc
le testament est déjà fait à priori sauf
s'il le change avant de mourir mais je
crois qu'il n'a pas plus vraiment les
capacités intellectuelles de le faire
donc là ça pourrait être suspicieux une
autre fois et là peut-être qu'en effet
les deux frères pourraient venir voir de
plus près ce qui se passe mais a priori
ça en effet c'est réglé et ça ne
changera pas alors pourquoi elle veut
déménager pour des soins en Suisse
est-ce que les soins sont meilleurs en
Suisse qu'en France je ne sais pas c'est
vrai que ça ça peut élever des questions
du côté des frères qui déjà sont dans la
suspicion depuis assez longtemps puis là
voilà tout explose mais alors quel est
le problème alors ça lui permettrait
aussi d'éviter la mise sous tutelle
c'est-à-dire queelle a peur que les
garçons exigent la mise sous tutelle he
ça avait été évoqué puisqu'il y a une
enquête sur la santé d'alindelon et si
jamais ça avait été décidé ça voudrait
dire que tout est remis en question mais
le procureur de montargie qui a étudié
l'affaire lui souhaitait la mise sous
tutelle mais pour le moment elle n'est
pas décidée h évidemmentil était en
Suisse il échapperait totalement à cette
possible mise soustitelle en France
alors Philippe persen vous êtes le
producteur des pièces d'Alain Delon vous
avez monté trois pièces avec alin Delon
sur la dernière il était également avec
Anouka donc sa fille comment il allait
déjà il allait très bien très très bien
avant toute chose c je trouve que ce ce
déballage sur la passe publique quand on
a eu la vie a eu Alain sa vie personnel
sa carrière je trouve ça d'une tristesse
vraiment je suis effondré d'ailleurs
tout comme Anouka j'ai eu elle m'a
envoyé un texto il y a 48 he pour me
dire papa et moi sommes effondrés et je
je t'assure c'est c'est très dur à
entendre quand on voit la personnalité
comment était Alain c'est c'est une bête
c'est une bête Alain on pensait pas en
arrivver là et je trouve ça vraiment
très très triste surtout pour Anouchka
parce que je pense qu'elle est dans la
ligne de mire de tous les médias elle le
mérite vraiment pas tu vois is moi quand
j'avais monté la route de Madison avec
Alain et mir dark derrière je voulais
faire un ce petit cadeau à Alain je
voulais lui dire tiens je je vais te
proposer de monter une une une une une
vraie une une vraie pièce avec avec sa
fille donc j'ai contacté Eric Assous on
a fait on a fait le cadeau on peut dire
à Alain pour lui dire tiens tu vas tu
vas pouvoir monter une pièce
avec avec ton père et voilà et c'est
c'est tout Anouka et tout sauf la fille
à papa il y en a beaucoup dans ce métier
beaucoup d'artistes ce sont les enfants
d'eux Anouka n pas du tout ce profil là
ils ont toujours été proche très proche
très très proche et heureusement que
Anouka était là sur la pièce d'ailleurs
la dernière pièce que j'ai monté avec
lui et et son père avec alin il était
toujours très très proche ouais alors au
niveau de ses fils il était il était
aussi proche de ses fils ou pas du tout
comme nous le dire Nicola oui ben moi je
je connais je connais la famille je
connais oui oui bien Antony
qu'infambbien bien sûr il vit
régulièrement à l'infamben sur la
dernière pièce veneit régulièrement voir
voir Alain sur la sur la journéere la
pièce que qu'on avait monté il y a en
2011 oui oui mais c'est vrai c'est vrai
c'est vrai qu'anouka était toujours
toujours toujours avec lui toujours même
sur les anci les pièces qu'on avait
monté ensemble Anouchka était alors on
peut pas dire ça préféré c'est vrai que
c'est compliqué à le dire c'est
difficile mais c'est vrai que ils
étaient fusionnels ils étaient très
proches tous les deux très très pr c'est
la réalité oui et c'est aussi sa plus
proche collaboratrice c'est ça qu'
puisque Anouska gère les sociétés en
Suisse Alain Delon il a ouvert sa
première société en Suisse en 1978 Alain
Delon diffusion à Genève en 99 il
obtient la double nationalité à ce
moment-là et c'est elle qui gère ensuite
aujourd'hui c'est elle qui gère et il
faut savoir que la marque la griffe
àinelon c'est extrêmement populaire
jusqu'à très récemment les parfums
àinelon ça cartonnait en Asie c'est elle
qui gère tout ça sur un sur iromi alors
qui est iromi et pourquoi c'est parce
que c'est c'est ça
commenc Ron téléspectateurs
quiom Rolin c'est la gouvernante l'
d'Alain Delon depuis des années qui se
prétend être sa compagne donc hom Rolin
les enfants elle aurait profité de la
faiblesse supposée d'Alain Delon pour
lui extorquer de l'argent voir le
menacer il y aura eu des menaces contre
le chien et cetera et cetera tout le
monde a porté plainte contre iromi Rolin
tous ont été déboutés c'estàdire qu'il y
a aucune charge retenue contre elle Homi
Rolin avait elle pé plainte pour
violence en réunion contre les enfants
elle a été déboutée donc aujourd'hui
cette action judiciaire s éteinte voilà
pour le moment il y a pas de charge mais
hirom mirolin est resté dans l'entourage
d'Alain Delon pendant extrêmement
longtemps et c'est elle qui a fait
éclater la cellule familiale avec cette
mise en lumière il avent le même avocat
oui ce momentl av le même avocat
personne qui défendit contre il étaent
ligué contre elle est-ce que vous
connaissiez truc je l'ai rencontré deux
fois don une fois à douchi quand j'étais
sur la première pièce avec Alain ouais
sur les montagnes ruses tout à fait
c'est tout mais je l'ai vu qu'une fois
elle venait jamais d'ailleurs au théâtre
venit nulle part non non du tout alors
le le parquet pour enquêter sur les les
plaintes à euh vu 50 témoins ils ont
saisi les comptes bancaires d'iromirolin
ils ont fait des perquisitions expertise
médicale d'alin Delon tous les téléphone
saisi et ils n'ont rien trouvé voilà
donc aujourd'hui on peut le dire c'est
classé sans suite elle n'est coupable de
rien puisquil y a pas d'action Judici
est où là maintenant il ils l'ont oui
elle n'avait plus le droit de ça c'est
ce que nous disait le responsable de la
de la sécurité hier elle a été écartée
du quotidien de la vie d'Alain Delon à
douchi
Nicolas je pense que c'était l'arbre qui
cachait la forêt en fait c'est une fois
qu'elle a disparu tout d'un coup tout
éclate au grand jour c'est-à-dire on
avait les enfants qui semblaient être
liés contre elle en disant on protège
notre père elle abuse de notre père et
quand tout d'un coup bah chacun porte
porte plainte les uns contre les autres
les les les les procédures s'éteignent
classer sans suite et tout d'un coup là
on voit les vrais visage entre
guillemets c'est un combat entre les
fils et Anouchka et c'est vrai que là
ben on étale tout au grand jour et là
cette fois-ci la solidarité fraternel
s'éteint et cette fois-ci bah c'est un
combat c'est qui protège le mieux les
intérêts de son père et cetera et cetera
donc oui c'est je pense que il y a eu
une histoire comme ça et puis voilà une
fois qu'il y avait plus homir Rolin bah
on voit la la de manière assez cynique
le le conflit familial mais j'ai envie
de dire c'est Alain Delon et on le voit
devant tout le monde et ça s'étale dans
Paris Match et dans tous les médias moi
dans dans mon cabinet il y a des
milliards de dossiers comme ça de
personnes lambda où des frères et des
sœurs s'entred dééchirent sur de
l'héritage donc et là il s'entredéchir
donc pour l'héritage qui c'est pas ce
qu'ils disent ils disent qu'ils
sonentreich pas pour
l'héritage le point desésaccord aussi
c'est
est-ce que enfin Alain Delon a toujours
dit qu'il voulait finir sa vie à douchi
et Anouka veut l'emmener en Suisse
Anthony Delon dit que c'est pour des
raisons fiscales quand même parce qu' il
est obligé d'être une certaine période
de l'année en Suisse pour bénéficier de
voilà fiscal donc il y a quand même
cette cette question de l'argent mais
qui n'est pas vraiment l'éritage nous
expliquer ça pour nos téléspectateurs
bah très simplement pour être résident
fiscal suisse il faut non
seulement il faut être citoyen donc alin
Delon a la la nationalité Suiss la
double nationalité franc en Suisse et en
plus il faut résider pendant une
certaine période continue en Suisse 6
mois et un jour enfin voilà c'est des
c'est la cuisine un peu juridique mais
c'est ce qui permet après de mettre sa
fiscalité et la fiscalité de sa
succession dont on sait qu'en France ça
tabasse quand même un peu en Suisse
c'est un peu plus léger ça permettra en
effet d'alléger la fiscalité sur sur la
mais il y a quand même quelque chose que
je comprends pas si la suc vous nous
dites que la succession est réglée oui
Anthony Delon dit c'est réglé on voit
bien à travers toutes les prises de
position qu'il y a encore un enjeu
financier donc essayez de nous expliquer
quel peut-être l'enjeu financier est-ce
que c'est la gestion encore des
entreprises à l'IND de longon est-ce que
là là-dessus il y a une part qui peut
encore être redistribuée ou est-ce qu'il
s'agit pas du tout d'argent alors c'est
c'est indirectement lié je pense à
l'argent puisqu'on sait que la
répartition est faite et qui touchera
plus et qui touchera moins mais c'est
encore une fois sur la pérénisation de
l'œuvre comment on va décider comment on
vend les films comment on continue les
licences à l'in Delon les cigarettes les
briquets qui aura de pouvoir a priori ce
serait herdouchka mais est-ce que elle
aurait pas orienté un peu son père
est-ce qu'elle prendra pas des décisions
contradictoires avec ce que veulent
laisser eux les les les frères qui ont
été un peu moins bien privilégiés par un
de l' donc il a aussi ça ça se joue
alors la la question aujourd'hui
vraiment qui est prépondérante c'est
comment est-ce que Alain Delon a encore
toute sa tête est-ce que vous l'avez eu
vous Philippe Meren dernièement est-ce
que non depuis un an j'ai pu nouvelle d'
on s'envoie des textos régulèement pour
les fêtes pour les vœux bon on a on est
on a des rapports on a vraiment des très
bons rapports j'avais la chance d'avoir
des rapports on peut dire des très bons
rapports avec Alain donc non depuis un
an c'est un peu plus difficile on s'est
vu 1 an après ça sa Palme d'Or à Cannes
en 2019 2020 et depuis c'est un petit
peu ouais il y a pas beaucoup de retour
ouais mais je sais je sais que c'est
c'est compliqué pour lui je sais que
Anouka me l'a dit c'est compliqué pour
papa il a une santé il a très flè ouis
ouais c'est pas c'est pas évident du
tout ça c'est l'enjeu majeur parce que
effectivement on a des rumeurs
extrêmement contradictoires mais s'il
s'il va vraiment mal comme l'insinuait
par exemple le procureur de Montargis
qui a évoqué une mise sous tutelle mise
sous curatelle à ce moment-là tout peut
être remis en question pour l'héritage
Anouchka elle elle dit il va bien et on
voit bien que les deux fils accentuent
le côté mais il signe des papiers sans
le savoir il fait n'importe quoi il n'a
plus toute sa tête parce que les deux
garçons eux clairement veulent une mise
sous tutelle mais mais quand il avit
quand vous le voyez vous et quand Alain
Delon était était voilà totalement
lucide vous avez av vous l'avez dit tous
les deux vous voyez bien il avait quand
même voilà un faible pour Anouka
complèement bien sûr oui ils étaient
très très proche alin Anouka était
vraiment très très proche bien sûr donc
on peut comprendre que lui son son désir
c'est de donner 50 % Anka 25
25 quand est-ce qu'il a fait le
testament si le testament a été fait
quand il était complèementaccord la
succession a été réglé avant avant ses
problèmes de problèm de santé donc en
fait je vois pas en fait je vois pas le
le sujet en fait si si le sujet c'est ce
que je dis c'est qu'il y a quelque chose
derrière c'est l'image l'image Comment
va être va être pérénisé l'image de leur
père peut-être qu'ils seront en
contradiction làdessus avec Anouka on
sait pas mais il y a quelque chose il y
a une amertume je pense che chez Anthony
Delon et peut-être chez chez chez son
petit frère parce que justement ils ont
été moins aimés que que que leur sœurs
et donc ils estiment que peut-être ils
auront pas suffisamment leur mots à dire
et ça ça les à partir du moment où on
imagine que c'est elle qui aura la
gestion des sociétés ça veut dire que le
seul usufruit et la seule façon de
péréniser la marque c'est elle
c'est il vontou5% et sera terminors que
elle pourer de fairevec avec cette
problématique c'est que là on parle de
du versant patrimonial de de la
succession mais chez les artistes il y a
toujours un versant de droit moral et le
droit moral c'est l'image et ça
normalement le le celui qui qui qui qui
organise sa succession doit le partager
entre ses enfants donc est-ce que là on
aura pas des conflits entre les trois
enfants sur il y a beaucoup de choses
qui vont qui vont for forcément à
devenir Philiipe est-ce que vous avez
des nouvelles de vous avez des nouvelles
que d'anouka Anouka oui parce que je
suis très proche d'elle c'est vrai je le
cach pas très proche d'elle et
régulièrement on est en contact
d'ailleurs vous la sentez sin vous fondr
elle m'aenvoyé un texto il y a de jours
je l'avais eu il y a un petit mois parce
que je lui proposé un projet de pièce
ensemble elle a décliné parce qu'elle
était sur d'autres projets
cinématographiqu ou télé mais oui on se
pas régulièrement avec kanouka bien sûr
ouais ou ouais et vous la vous la sentez
sincère ah complètement an auun doute
parce que quand vous entendez ces frères
dire que c'est une machination et cetera
enfin crois pas pre moi crois pas du
tout du tout je pense que Al malgré
Alain malgré sa maladie c'est quand même
Alain de long voilà donc il sait il sait
où il va là il sait c'est vrai que le
fait d'être très proche d'anouka voilà
il y a un audio quand même qui pose
question que que Alain Fabien mis
enou et on a sentiment quand même que
Alain Delon est pas là enfin et qu'elle
lui parle un peu de façon virulente il
entend pas il paraîit qu'il entend pas
il pe pr des problèmes d'audition c'est
un fait bien sûr oui Daniel oui en fait
on se dit comment ça va se terminer
parce que là c'est atroce enfin il y a
quand même des enfants qui se déchirent
et le le père est toujours vivant enfin
on par là regardez depuis un moment on
parle de quelqu'un qui est encore vivant
ça c'est c'est le plus horrible bon ça
c'est une chose et en fait là je crois
que cette semaine le procureur est train
de auditionner tous les membres de la
famille tout pour savoir justement il y
a un espèce de mystère pour savoir s'il
est conscient pas conscient donc cette
semaine il il va faire vraiment comme un
audit en fait il va il va demander les
témoignages de tout le monde toutes les
personnes concernées et apparemment la
semaine prochaine on saurait s'il va
être sous tutelle sir parce qu'il faut
que ça se termine ce que me dit Fabien
lecvre il me dit tout le conflit tout le
conflit sur la gestion des sociétés de
long ce qui explique le vrai désaccord
donc c'est ça parce que c'est Anouka qui
gère les seulement 50% collaborat la
plus proche tout à fait absolument
vérité c'est pas l'éritage le problème
oui mais ça fait partie de
l'héritage qui g en moment exactement
c'est elle qui gè en ce moment tout à
fait c'est ça qui pose problème tout à
fait donc c'est c'est vraiment le le ner
de la guerre il est làin g bien sûr
c'est elle qui gère alors maintenant la
grande question aussi c'est est-ce
qu'alinelon va d'une manière ou d'une
autre vouloir s'exprimer on sait que lui
a toujours dit quand je serai diminué
c'est fini je me retire je ne parle plus
parler non mais est-ce qu'il ferait un
témoignage écrit quelque chose parce que
là sinon ça je pense que seul lui peut
mettre un terme à cette affaire pour le
moment VO bien sû merci Philippe merci
Nicolas merci à tous d'avoir été avec
nous tout de suite western sur C8
merci